Hi, my name is Sebastian.
I'm actually an entrepreneur,
and I'm super excited about
the Tech Entrepreneurship Manage Degree
because it teaches you how
to become an entrepreneur.
Now what's great about an entrepreneur,
entrepreneurs change the world.
They dream, they reach for
the stars and then they make it happen.
They understand how to
get the world to change,
how to make the world a better place.
And being an entrepreneur
means you can do it yourself,
you have no boss just do it and
every mistake is your own mistake.
Now I haven't always
been an entrepreneur.
I used to be at Stanford teaching
as a computer science professor.
I actually had tenure which
is a lifetime position, so
it was very comfortable at
a fantastic university.
And at some point I got a little bored
by all the security that I had and
figured I've gotta do
something bigger than that.
And then moved over to a search
engine company called Google.
And I started Google X,
self driving cars, Google Glass,
Project Loon, a whole bunch of projects.
And these are all crazy projects
that I could do at Google.
But in Udacity,
this is my biggest moonshot so
far, so
really trying to change the world.
Now I'm not here to tell
you about my company,
I'm here to tell you,
make your own company.
You can duplicate this.
If you take this Tech Entrepreneurship
Manage Degree, you learn the nuts and
bolts, how to be successful.
And your going to work many many
mistakes that I have to make because
none of this exist when I started.
The great thing about this not
a degree is that you're going to build
your own stuff.
You basically believe your own mini
company as part of your training which
is you're going to build
the first version of your product.
You develop a monetization strategy,
you get your first users
of customers on board and we even teach
you how to pitch to potential investors.
All the stuff we do in real life,
now in your
Tech Entrepreneurship Manage Degree.
So welcome to another degree and
I see you in class.